much do you have to pay monthly for
steroids that really just depends what's
the range they're cheaper than
supplements really how long have you
been on steroids three years what did it
do to your penis dick nothing balls like
I said earlier it's like a Brazilian
butt lift for your testicles which is
good for middle-aged white men why are
you sack oh you guys sag that's your
style
does it make your dick bigger it
actually can increase blood flow to
every area oh there's hope so I went
from like a solid two and a half to like
2.75 wow percentage-wise that's not bad
become girls when they take steroids
their clits get all huge that's a
viralization effect masculine features
that occur so is it turning into a penis
no oh
sexual organs just get more blood flow
to them and it can it can grow the
clitoris I Wonder If They Come Harder oh
they do oh